French novelist
Andre Malraux said
that man is not what
he thinks he is.
He is what he hides.
And you know what?
I think he was on to something.
Hey, everyone.
Laci Green here for D News.
When we're little kids, we first
learn about secrets by, say,
keeping a birthday
present a surprise.
And it's so fun.
But as we age, and our lives
become more complicated,
so do our secrets.
Then secrets become not as fun.
But, hey, that's part of
the grand disappointment
that is adulthood.
Maybe you secretly hate someone.
Maybe you're secretly
a disgusting human
who does gross stuff
when you're alone.
Don't lie.
I know you all have
some nasty habits.
Or maybe you have
sexual secrets,
common ones being masturbating,
cheating on a partner,
or hiding your
sexual orientation.
Psychologists believe that the
ability to keep small secrets
is a sign of good mental health.
There's a time and a place
for sharing some things,
you know what I mean?
I'm talking about
those TMI secrets.
Have a secret or two
about ourselves has also
been shown to help us
develop a sense of self
outside of the crowd,
which is a positive thing
for our identities.
But what about big secrets?
Damaging secrets?
Secrets that eat you
from the inside out,
secrets that you hold
onto, maybe for years.
Scientists have found that these
kind of secrets are bad news.
A study in the International
Journal of Behavioral
Development found
that young adults who
admitted they were
keeping a secret
had lower levels of
self control, higher
levels of loneliness
and depression,
and their personal
relationships were compromised.
The researchers checked back
in with them six months later,
and those who had
revealed their secrets
showed a dramatic
improvements in symptoms.
At the end of the
study, they found
that the women were more
likely than men to have secrets
and that they were also
less likely to share them.
Another super interesting
study published
in the Journal of Social
Psychology and Personality
Science found that
secrets actually
feel physically burdensome.
You know how people talk about
having baggage or feeling
heavy?
People in the
study who were told
to focus on a
personal secret judged
hills to be steeper and
distances to be longer
than they actually
were, while people
who were given the opportunity
to tell their secret
felt no such burden.
So in case you needed more
proof that keeping a secret
feels like crap,
and telling someone
can be the greatest relief
ever, now you have it.
The good news-- or
maybe the bad news,
depending on how
you look at it--
is that, one way or
another, our brains usually
find a way to purge itself
of distressing secrets.
Harvard neuroscientist
Laura Smart
explains that when we
try to suppress a secret,
a mental process called ironic
monitoring unconsciously kicks
in.
Its surveys unwanted
thoughts, eventually
bringing them bubbling to the
surface, where they become
a part of the intentional
operating process, which
is our conscious awareness.
In other words,
secrets haunt you
until they're allowed
to break free.
So, peeps, I really
care about you,
and I don't want you to
have any nervous breakdowns,
so today's comment board
will be a confessional.
Spill your secrets down
below, and walk away
a healthier person.
Thanks for joining
me for D News.
I'll see you next time.